for years we've created renders that
have brought satisfaction peace
tranquility but in honor of this season
it's time to do the opposite instead of
lowering heart rates we'll be raising
them Sam Peter Ren and myself have spent
days devising the most terrifying CGI
renders and Nico will watch them all
while attached to a heart rate monitor
whoever can Spike that little heart of
his the most will win a Halloween themed
prize who a prize
you guys know there was a prize there's
a prize what's the prize probably
probably just candy ah or is it a trick
we'll find
[Music]
out Nico how are you feeling leading up
to the big event look I've seen things
I've experienced things we'll see if you
have what it takes to shake my cold
frozen heart out of its locked 60 BPM
the reason we chose nik nik is the
chillest guy we've ever met we've
measured Niko's average resting heart
rate and found it almost never rises
above 60 BPM medical fact if we can get
it north of that we've done something
special here if we can scare Nico we can
scare anybody Sam I think I want to see
you render first please spook
me I've been excited for the spooky
render all year because normally these
renders have been kind of fun you know
they're satisfying to make you go ooh ah
and so it's a really nice mixup here to
go into a little different vibe here
something maybe a little more each uh uh
uh when I first sat down the first thing
I thought was spooky little guys that
you can barely catch a glimpse of that's
like usually the best thing that works
in horror movies oh my
God model the spooky
guy that's it Sam this is the best
character you could model and I would be
like yeah witness how good I am at
modeling it doesn't matter how good it
is because you're barely going to see it
the creepiness is going to come from the
map that I perform and put on to this
character I had to be a creeper I had to
get in the mind of a creeper and creep
around look at that look at me master of
fear here by the way I don't know if you
knew that look at this Spooky Walk that
I'm doing bone chilling isn't it I even
got on the ground that's right I'm
dedicated I love unreal I've been
sitting on this super cool spooky
Mansion it was a free one by the way and
looking at it it's like okay this is a
perfect area for a huge kind of like
hide and seek game the moment I started
looking at this and putting it together
I was like you know what we really fun
too on top of this simulate this is all
being filmed on a phone or something
like that one thing that really inspired
this whole render for me was that really
cool game called unrec they're doing a
few things they have very realistic
lighting they also have very realistic
camera animation it looks like you're
watching a body cam or a GoPro on
someone I decided to take that approach
to this render making sure my lighting
is all using like paths racing so it
looks like physically real but then the
kicker is getting some natural handheld
camera animation on this whole thing I
literally just walked around the studio
a bunch literally with my phone I used
camra AR it's recording the actual 3D
motion of the camera so I'm able to take
that rotation data and the shake data
and apply that to my virtual digital
camera in unreal honestly starts
bringing it all together and makes the
whole render look way more realistic I
mean look this render we'll see if it
chills your bones or not but I got a lot
of Hope for these little dudes all I can
hope for is just to release them out in
the world and hope they scare you
[Music]
Tobe
oh
[Music]
that
got my heart right up just uh was
showing it to you guys not trying to get
embarrassed this is a really cool Vibe I
like the little the little gu is like
every moment there's like you can kind
of see him there then he's gone and the
sound dude the sound design was awesome
it's little spooky my Rend is a little
spooky guys I think I succeeded um my
heart rate went down by 10 BP I'm
[Music]
watching I don't know there's something
comforting about it it's Sam made a
lovely render and maybe that's not what
he was going for but I quite enjoyed it
and once again maybe that's not what he
was going for now some people know know
my next request by the name sir render
but I know him by his given name Ren the
reaper please spook me
Ren I thought this would be easier to do
it's like a weird sort of like VFX
writers block I had a vague idea of what
I wanted to accomplish here I'm inspired
by this account that I've seen on Tik
Tok called lights are off they put out
tons of these really sick renders that
are kind of creepy so I want some sort
of jump scare but I need to find some
sort of misdirection like oh you think
this is going to be the Scary Part B
no I I started by just browsing the
internet for some sick 3D models like
look at this eyeball look how sick that
eyeball is what can I do with the time I
have
left looks like a little slug maybe
there's this like little eyeball
slithering down the hallway and I'm like
oh what's this cute little slug doing
here so yeah I guess next steps for me
is just like start the hardest step to
take is the first
[Music]
one got one more day I have one more day
and I've got a lot of work ahead of me
but I think think I got this boy maybe I
don't got this maybe I don't got this
Griffin do I got
this you got me got you no you're way oh
man okay I think I'm going to have a
swarm of little eyeball worms hundreds
of them right
just but I want to have it be like kind
of found footage is I'm going to do a
camera move with my actual phone using
an app called omniscient it's going to
let me basically choreograph the move in
real life and then give me a 3D camera
that I can drop into the scene I've
already been building deadlines and
limitations really help refine the idea
itself creativity thrives Under Pressure
I mean that is actually one of the the
nice things about the render challenge
it's both a blessing and a curse it's
like everyone always wants to have more
time to work on stuff but it really
forces you to sort of like focus on what
is important and more importantly to
move on once you're done I got to
[Applause]
[Music]
go
damn dang that's a great Loop the sound
design is great R this is this this is
magnum opus when it comes to sound
design wow okay the turn reveal was
fantastic that that jolted my heart yeah
it sure did that's what I was going for
that genuinely spooked me with the
running why is that so scary it is my
heart rate went down only 5 BPM with
this one it went down what what are you
talking about this one's great this was
super spooky down
you know they say twisted minds think
alike so Jordan let's see what kind of
eyeballs you have scaring across your
hospital
floors everyone's had a chance to scare
me here okay Peter dove into my deepest
darkest fears and made me face it in VR
oh dude it's right out of the freaking
dream Ren found out that I have a slight
trophobia issue don't do this well it's
my turn it's my turn to get Hearts
pumping man I'm reaching back through
the anals of time this is a fear that
has gripped countless children since Toy
Story came out you know what I'm talking
about this thing do you remember this
thing this cursed a
generation this is what I wanted to root
my creepy render on right I took a a
little bit of Liberty with the design
instead of just like a hook claw I added
some razor blades to the end of it and
of course we've got you know blood
smeared over its face so we've got our
character but the toughest part about a
spider character is the animation right
there's six legs
there's eight legs did you know they
have eight legs and I don't want to be
there painstakingly animating one leg
after the other we don't have a lot of
time to do this challenge so luckily
there's an artist Jose Molino who
actually designed a spider rig for
Houdini all I do is animate a character
along a single curve and the solver
takes care of the rest it looks at all
the different legs on the rig and goes
okay if you're moving this far in each
frame how much do each leg need to move
in order to keep up with that motion if
I was doing traditional animation would
have taken me ages so we have the
creepiest character I can think of baby
face but then when we're talking setting
Where would be the worst place for this
in my opinion hospital no one wants to
be there nothing good comes from going
there except for getting better that's
good but when you go there you're not
good so creepy a lot of death in that
zone right if you're walking alone in a
hospital Corridor and you realize
there's no one around you and all of a
sudden those lights start going wonky
that's pretty creepy but the problem is
with so many lights in my scene
animating all those lights would take
ages but you don't have to if you do it
in compositing I used what's called a
multipass exr it means that when I'm
actually compositing in Nuke I can
isolate each light and I can literally
dial the intensity of each light in the
compositing phase now instead of having
to wait 10 seconds to see the render of
that light everything is hyper flexible
Everything Is Broken Out and put back
together and you can just tweak to your
heart's content so the ability to dial
in what you can and can't see to play
with the Shadows a little bit it makes a
big impact on the eeriness of the scene
the imagination fills in the gaps for us
look last render challenge I went for
cute what
you this is my first foray into creepy
but I'm confident that this is creepy
enough to get those hearts pounding so
Ren Peter I'm going to pound your little
hearts was that
[Music]
intimidating
I oh my god dude this is incredible oh
my God H it's funny how you and ren made
very very similar renders I mean granted
mine's first person too my favorite part
is that little glimpse of the little
baby spider running after you when you
like turn back like and it's like you
can see it just it's still going you
know he's on your tail yeah I really
like the creature design in Jordan's and
he has like some cool dialogue I think
Jordan's the first one to have like
really intricately animated animated
lights which is kind of cool you tied
Ren for the amount of uh heart rate
going down hey hey great mind think I
like
brother guys why are we why are we doing
this let's bring we need another judge
we
need my gym teacher would be
disappointed because I'm not uh getting
the cardio rate I need to be getting and
uh you know Peter You're My Last Hope
please summon the darkness and summon my
high heart rate all right you also I'm
working on the spooky ocean render and
uh it's time to break down the render so
first things first we're going to need
some models and I'm not going to model
that stuff myself cuz I'm lazy so I'm
going to go over to CG Trader which is a
great resource I'm a big fan of Alin
Merl's work he made the scuba suit and a
bunch of other stuff I've used also
found a ship model a Shark model threw
those in blender added some materials
and now it's time to animate so for the
animation I used a mixture of mixo which
are just canned animations you can
download and a little bit of hand
animation where mixo wasn't cutting it
the most difficult part of this was
getting the look of the ocean to look
great I noticed in a lot of underwater
videos you see those little particles
swimming around that the flashlight is
close to them so I decided to add a
particle system with just some floaty
little spheres tiny little
spheres you know just making their way
around and uh when you shine flashlight
at them it looks like dust in the ocean
another thing I realized which is
actually mentioned in a recent react
video is that you can't see many colors
when you're deep underwater instead of
figuring out the color science of how to
you know treat transform the colors to
look the right way I just used blue
lights and there you go that's how I did
my underwater render I hope you like it
I don't know how scary the final render
is going to be but I scared the B Jesus
out of myself about 20 times working on
this the shark would be right there and
it made me jump quite a few times I hope
it scares the hell out of you and you
never want to watch a quarter video
again
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
that's pretty good Peter
whoa what the heck man that's pretty
good it captured creepy really well like
it's such an unsettling atmosphere not
being able to see like 5T in front of
you you know it's really cinematic this
cut to the wide angle of the boat I
think the Stillness of the character
before he gets eaten actually really
goes a long way towards making the shark
more shocking Peter you uh my heart rate
stayed the same what what what we did it
we did
it dang it why are you so
[Music]
scary that I can't
unse I didn't
know wait you're eating the
prize wait was that the pr
surprise well I have another
one what the heck is this realistically
at the end of the day the scientific
measurement turned out not to be the
heart rate but turned out to be the
clearly nervous giggle that I gave out
when the shark came and bit the
beer and I was like oh Peter won wow wow
we're back baby all right Peter close
your eyes Close Your Eyes Peter you
going get the
priz right hold out your
hand yeah you can take
one it's a
treat
you I got
it thank you Nico this means a lot to me
yeah do you all those in one goal didn't
win hey hey I this is getting out of
hand now he C he caught he caught me
that's hey they didn't win they're
taking treats you get back here you get
back here they didn't win and they're
taking all the treats those treats are
for
me looks like I'm the real winner here
if you're sad that this video is over
don't worry about it we have a whole
bunch of creative art challenges such as
Bob Ross with sauce what happens when
you try to follow a Bob Ross tutorial
but you can only use sauces instead of
paints it's surprising how the results
are so
tasty guess you have to click to find
out what I mean by that you swallow
it oh click it already
man I have an
m&
ow